welcome to this video playing mr. happy
from Australia sir do I know it no the
sky no name so very new very new account
only played a couple of moves a couple
of moves a couple of games quite high
rating to 480 ok playing the red team in
gambit fashion black can now take it and
can keep the pawn ok this is this is a
bit rare but not bad especially this
line leads to fairly solid play for
black you recognize that I play this
quickly I have some experience with the
line also an over the board plane I did
I forget to play a form you can play be
five now maybe the general idea is rook
t1 and then deform i was playing this
really quickly maybe too quickly
something like b5 before
hmm is taking some time now at least
it's an IM with those new accounts you
sometimes need to be aware of cheetahs
but the title player you can assume that
this is all all fine Queen B 6 mm that's
a strange move I don't really understand
what it is doing ok prevent it before
for the moment of course but other than
that the queen is strangely placed on b6
that's interesting idea yeah interesting
an interesting way to prevent them to
prevent the fall for the time being I
could go to see to maybe maybe play a
positional move first complete
development and then consider where to
put the Queen I was thinking Quincy to
d4 but this is not necessarily the the
best place to put it and it's also
possible to play entirely different
strategy on the Kings side down the King
certain my yolks are not especially well
placed for King side play thought maybe
he ran deform okay this might run into
Bishop c5
hmm yeah maybe still
yeah before
yeah true this is so this is a problem
if I like to play yeah this is really a
this type of position as a typical
example of why an opening like the ready
which looks a bit a bit conservative at
first can be a really fighting opening
you get positions where very little
pieces I exchanged we got all pieces on
the board and it's very tense many ideas
possible if you compare that to some
lines let's say in the petrol for the
the berlin wall or something you have
half the half the pieces exchanged and
iron in some sort of simplified position
this does not happen here it does
sometimes this is chess that happens the
blue fication but very often you have
this kind of complicated battles where
all pieces on the board
interesting all interesting maybe queen
bee six now it probably needs to do that
where else otherwise I probably maybe I
can cannot take on a seven evil queen
bee seven rook eight seven nights always
have Bishop c5 yeah I rather go here
yeah you can if I don't go to a one you
can take you for but Devon is hanging if
he now takes here I can take a seven and
I have some awesome ideas myself with
him I don't know what what you would
play now I can I have 95 for example
this is the strongest and his be
spending oh this is stupid now he had
covered the a porn and I i simply i
simply ignored it I'm very unnecessary
but had a very good physician hmm
okay let's get them get some play on the
Kings side
Knight f6 maybe just my first move that
may at age six he can go kick can move
the king kara come on you two need to do
something this is what really block
block this Bishop I need I need Bishop
before though check
now he can pre can promote all the time
and he does not for some reason be one
check
seven seconds hmm snow made threat right
time warning checkmate Wow haha what the
tense game yeah this one what's it died
early incorrect probably I mean I just
had to had to do something because I had
plundered the pond I was so happy about
the idea 95 it is it's nice that I that
I forgot to to protect my bone I think
you were protected i can do with rookie
one for example i should be in a should
be in good shape um not divorce even
better even better ah this is I didn't
see at all a very good move computer
move yeah and it's it's a pin and win
situation yeah this means that after d4i
needs to retreat and this is what this
is basically busted to be honest I've
got a full center and the two bishops
yeah yeah this is this is very bad for
black and well this I just blended this
and now it gets it's just like the
wounded box are looking for the lucky
punch and of course and I'm completely
lost them no question yeah heat can take
on the wall and promote he didn't I mean
you can just promote him and this will
win and this oh this is also winning i'm
not saying it's not check yeah there you
found the right defense age 5 verse
winning this is just at most confusion
he's got 11 seconds
yeah now can I mean creepy five for
example wins with Queen f1 net okay just
just lucky but I had had a really good
position before I just blended the
all-important 33 born okay thanks for
watching